Transfer tools have a number of uses.
Here are the basic steps for transferring
stitches. With the single prong tool,
place it over the hook of the needle.
Pull the tool and the needle back,
allowing the stitch
to fall behind the latch.
Push the tool and the needle forward.
The stitch should
automatically close the latch.
Keep pushing until the stitch slips off
the needle and transfers to the tool.
To replace the stitch on a needle
to create an eyelet or work a decrease,
place the hole of the tool over
the hook of the new needle.
Tilt the tool up and allow
the stitch to slip onto that needle.
When the stitch is securely in the hook of
the needle, remove the prong of the tool.
Use the same steps to use a two,
three, or multiprong tool.
Place the tool over the hooks
of the needles to be transferred,
pull out the tool and the needles until
the stitches are behind the latches.
Push back to close the latch
and slip the stitches onto the tool.
Tilt the tool up and replace
the stitches as needed.
Be sure to put the emptied needles
into working position and you
can continue knitting.
In this example, I left the empty
needle in out of work position.
When I knit across, the yarn
traveled between the stitches.
I then put the needle in work and continued
knitting. But you can see that I
have an extra-large eyelet.